Uh second question I had was uh uh
Judges 11:19.
>> Yep.
>> Uh it says here uh and the Lord was
>> they could drive them out because they
had uh chariots of iron,
>> right? So I was just wondering, you
know, you know, God had um given them
everybody else that they fought against.
Well, why would this matter at all?
>> No, because it wasn't God's purpose for
them to be driven out completely. It's
not in only Judges 117 to19. So let me
show it to you.
>> Okay.
>> The Lord already said he would drive
them up slowly, not completely for two
reasons. Number one, they were too young
and they were immature when it came to
fighting. And also, there are too many
animals that if they were all driven out
at once, the animals might be too much
to handle because they're so numerous
like bears and lions and so forth.
Right.
>> Okay. And number two, the other reason
why God did not allow them to drive them
out completely was because of
punishment. Because they did not fully
submit to the law of the Lord and
decided to then worship their gods and
goddesses as they entered in. So here is
the same book. Here it is right there
spelled out black and white. But let's
read it. Judges 2:105. Then the angel
Lord went up from Gilgal to Boim and
said, "I brought you up out of Egypt,
led you into the land I swore to give to
your ancestors, and said, I will never
break my covenant with you, and you
shall not make a covenant with the
people of this land."
>> I'm on with with
>> Sam.
You want to say hello?
You sure? Come on. Come here.
>> No, it's too late now. Don't be scared.
>> No, he's calling for you now. Come on.
>> Come on now.
>> He means right there.
>> What? Say what?
>> Don't be scared. He mean
>> we watch. We watch you all the time.
Yeah. He said don't be scared.
>> Hey, she that means she's a great woman
if she watches me.
>> He said you're a great woman because you
watch him.
Great is your reward in the kingdom, Mr.
>> All right.
>> Okay. Sorry about that,
>> man. Now, the sacrifice you made to
marry you, brother. You better be
thankful.
>> I am, man. I am. I appreciate it.
>> Okay. Here's why he didn't drive them
out all at once. The angel that Jesus in
his pre existence, I brought you up out
of Egypt and led you into the land I
swore to give to your ancestors. I said,
I'll never break my covenant with you.
You shall not make a covenant with the
people of this land, but you shall break
down their altars. Yet you have
disobeyed me. Why have you done this?
And I have also said, I will not drive
them out before you. See here,
I will not drive them out before you.
They will become trs for you and their
gods will come snares to you.
>> When the angel of the Lord had spoken
these things to all the Israelites, the
people wept aloud. They called the place
bokeh. Boim there they offered sacrifice
Lord. Boim means weepings. Again, same
book.
Judges 2:19-23.
But when the judge died, the people
returned to ways even more corrupt than
those of their ancestors, following
other gods and serving and worshiping
them. They refused to give up their evil
practices, stubborn ways. Therefore, the
Lord was very angry with Israel and
said, "Because this nation has violated
the covenant I ordained for their
ancestors and has not listened to me, I
will no longer drive out before them any
of the nations Joshua left when he died.
I will use them to test Israel and see
whether they will keep the way of the
Lord and walk in in it as their
ancestors did." The Lord had allowed
those nations to remain. Why? He did not
dry them out at once by giving them to
the hands of Joshua because he just told
you two reasons. They're too young,
immature. They don't know warfare. They
don't know how to cultivate the land.
The animals are too numerous for them to
control. So, I'm going to keep them
around who know how to cultivate the
land who then help them fight against
the animals. But secondly, because of
their disobedience
and keeping covenant with these Gentiles
who worship gods and goddesses, I'm then
going to use them to punish Israel and
to repentance. Judges 3:es 1-6. Again,
says it right here. These are the
nations the Lord left to test all those
Israelites who had not experienced any
of the wars in Canaan. He did this only
to teach warfare to the descendants of
the Israelites who had no who had not
had previous battle experience. The five
rulers of the Philistines and all the
Canaanites, the Sidonians and the
Hivites living in Lebanon mountains from
Mount Ba Raman to Lebu, they were left
to test the Israelites to see whether
they would obey the Lord's commands
which he had given their ancestors
through Moses. The Israelites lived
among the Canaanites, Hittites,
Amorites, Perizzites, Hivites, and
Jebusites. Notice how they're breaking
God's command. They took their daughters
in marriage, gave their own daughters to
their sons, and serve their gods. So
you're already told not only in judges
God already said I'm not going to drive
them out completely because you are too
young too mature you can't handle the
land
and cultivating it or the animals the
bears and lions where you are too
numerous and secondly because you've
been proving yourselves to be faithless
over and over again I'm going to use
them to discipline you and beat you into
repentance.
So it's part of training them and
punishing them. Training them to know
how to fight, how to then run a land,
cultivate a land, how to control the
wild animals, but also to punish them
because they repeatedly broke his words
not only in the land but in the
wilderness.
>> Got it?
>> Yeah. In fact, let me then show you here
>> so that people don't think he already is
telling them here in Deuteronomy 7
22-23.
Oh, sorry.
What? Yep. God already announced this
beforehand that he's not going to wipe
them out completely.
Deuteronomy 7:22-23. Here it is. Look,
long before they entered the land,
right?
Here it is. The Lord your God will drive
out the nations before you little by
little.
>> Right? You will not be allowed to
eliminate them all at once. Or the wild
animals will multiply around you, but
the Lord your God will deliver them over
to you, throwing them into great
confusion until they are destroyed
little by little.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Yep.
>> And then two final ones. Exodus
23:29-30. But I will not drive them out
in a single year because the land would
become desolate and the wild animals too
numerous for you. Little by little, I
will drive them out before you unto have
increased enough to take possession of
the land. And finally, Exodus 13:17 18.
When Pharaoh let here's the principle,
let the people go. God did not lead them
on the road through the Philistine
country, though that was shorter. Why?
For God said if they face war, they
might change their minds and return to
Egypt. So God let the people around by
the desert rode toward the Red Sea. The
Israelites went up out of Egypt ready
for battle because they're not battle
trained and they may be intimidated and
cower.
>> Got you.
>> Perfect. So just the the iron chariots
that just happened to be what they said
stop them, but no matter what it was
going to be little by little
>> it was
>> he was never going to give it fully over
to them at that time
>> because the God who split the Red Sea
and brought the plagues. You think he
couldn't just destroy the chariots? But
he didn't. He let them struggle against
iron chariots to teach them, look,
you're not as great as you think you
are, and you're nothing without me. See,
you can even dry them up because they
had iron chariots. So, what do you think
they would do to them if I'm not with
you?
>> Teaching them not to trust in their own
military might and prowess, but to be
humble because this is a sign. Look, you
couldn't even defeat them because they
had iron chariots. You think you could
defeat anyone if it wasn't for me? to
teach them to depend on him, not on
their might, intelligence, resources, or
military prowess.
>> Got you. Thank you, Sam. See, that's why
you wanted one of the warriors, man.
That's why.
>> Well, have your wife and you pray for me
that as you guys ask to be filled the
spirit finish race, I stay holy and not
shame the Lord and finish the race.
>> I will. We'll definely have have you in
our prayers, man. I appreciate it.
>> Love you, brother.
>> Love you, too.
>> God bless. All right.
>> Do you guys understand his question? If
I throw you out, it's to make more room,
guys. It's not anything personal. Okay,
you guys understand the question? These
questions are excellent. Now, you're
learning a lot if you're listening.